avec alain gautier les co fondateurs du
collectif des parties civiles pour le
rwanda
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france
alors on vous connaît bien puisque vous
traquer les génocidaires au rwanda mais
pas seulement au rwanda en 2005 d'abord
pour revenir sur les faits et qui
concerne donc la responsabilité de la
france qui n'aurait pas empêché le
massacre des tutsis dans les collines de
bisesero vous y êtes rendu à plusieurs
reprises que pouvez-vous nous dire sur
cette responsabilité présumée de la
france dans les faits enfin pour nous si
vous voulez il ne fait aucun doute et on
le répète depuis de très nombreuses
années le rôle de la france non
seulement dans le génocide des tutsi du
rwanda mais en particulier sur les
collines de baisser ses taux pour nous
ne fait pas l'ombre d'un doute
malheureusement
le procureur de paris demanda ce qui est
un non lieu
la décision n'est pas encore prise
officiellement puisque le dernier mot
reviendra au juge d'instruction
mais il est à craindre que cette
décision soit soit confirmée et les les
associations parties civiles dans ce
dossier ainsi que les peuples et les
personnes personnes physiques
évidemment trouve cette décision
irrecevable pourquoi à votre avis le
parquet demandait un non-lieu dans la
sphère de bisesero vous savez on est
dans un contexte un petit peu spéciale
depuis quelques semaines vous savez que
il ya eu de la part de la france d'abord
le rapport du clerc qui n'a pas voulu se
prononcer pour une complicité dans le
génocide des tutsi et puis le quelques
jours plus tard c'est le rwanda qui a
fait connaître son rapport et qui lui
non plus n'évoque pas la responsabilité
là la complicité de l'état français avec
le génocide
donc on est dans une période je dirais
un petit peu de réconciliation entre
entre nos deux pays et je crois que il
va être difficile d'imaginer que les
juges d'instruction prennent une
décision différente
a moins comme le réclament des
associations parties civiles
une information que l' enquête soit
relancé et ça je pense qu'il faut pas
trop rêver
ce que l'on reproche aux militaires
français à l'époque
c'est d'avoir fermé les yeux sur
l'arrivée de génocidaires qui ont
organisé des attaques massives contre
les tutsis qui était présent à à
bisesero à l'époque on parle de 50 mille
morts oui parce qu'on reproche surtout
aux militaires de l'opération turquoise
c'est entre le 27 et le 30 juin 1994
d'avoir laissé sur les collines de
distiller ses lots un certain nombre
nombre important de rescapés tutsi entre
les mains des miliciens il ne l'a avoué
hutu et pendant ces trois jours là alors
que la présence des militaires français
avaient fait sortir les rescapés de leur
cachette
eh bien les tueurs en en profiter
lorsque les militaires français sont
repartis pour exécuter un certain nombre
de ces rescapés
c'est cette période là de trois jours
que le des associations qui se sont
constituées partie civile évoque dans
cette plainte alors les parties civiles
réclament une poursuite des
investigations sur la base on parlait du
rapport duclair donc sur la base des
travaux de ce rapport remis au président
de la république
sur quels éléments du rapport repose
cette demande non précisément je pense
que les parties civiles ne peuvent pas
s'appuyer sur leur apportant du clerc
libre qui refuse d'évoquer de toute
complicité
ce que les associations réclament c'est
que pour relancer une enquête c'est que
soit entendu de nouveaux témoins
en particulier tout ce que dans le
rapport du clair on est molle que les
proches du président mitterrand
quand on parle des proches du président
mitterrand on évoque les conseillers
militaires
qu'est-ce nos élus chantent quand on
évoque aussi le secrétaire général de
l'elysée de l'époque monsieur védrine
mais je crains que les juges n'accepte
pas cette demande de relancer l' enquête
et comment vous l'expliquez une fois
encore c'est explicable joue des dans la
mesure où l'opération le le rapport du
plaira très peu avaient stieg et dans
[Musique]
l'opération turquoise parce que il avait
très peu d'archivés d'après ce qu'on
nous a dit ça paraît difficile
effectivement de d'aller au delà
la seule solution ce serait d'entendre
deux nouveaux témoins mais je le répète
connaissent un petit peu le monde de la
justice connaissant cette affaire qui
traîne depuis un certain nombre d'années
eh bien je crois que de part et d'autre
en france et au rwanda
on veut plutôt allait vers l'apaisement
et voilà c'est un peu sur le dos des
rescapés que ça va se produire le
rapport du clerc qui évoque une faillite
militaire et politique
il parle d' aveuglement de la france et
un autre rapport dont il faut aussi
parler c'est le rapport commandé par le
rwanda à des avocats américains
ce rapport à lui il souligne une lourde
responsabilité de la france dans le
génocide des tutsis en 1994 et refuse
toujours et affirme que la france refuse
toujours finalement de reconnaître son
rôle dans cette stratégie
tragédie est ce que ce rapport rwandais
il peut en quelque sorte remettre en
cause les investigations menées dans le
cadre du rapport duclair a non je pense
que quand on y regarde de plus près on
se rend compte que les deux rapports
dont dans le même sens le rapport
duclair et bob de lourdes
responsabilités de l'état français en
particulier des proches du président du
terran et le rapport du rwanda et boch
exactement la même chose
une nuance à la main il ya une nuance
alain gautier le lan 92 estiment que la
france savait qu'un génocide se préparer
mais a continué à apporter un soutien
indéfectible selon ses mots régime du
président hutu juvénal habyarimana dont
l'assassinât a provoqué ce génocide
oui la france savait mais nous le
répétons depuis depuis très longtemps
il ya des gens très bien placé à cette
époque là qui parlait déjà d'un génocide
prévisible puisque c'est
le terme employé par le rapport du
rwanda mais personne ne veut aller
jusqu'à la complicité
donc même si il ya une différence entre
les deux rapports les deux rapports dont
le même sens on est les deux rapports
qui exclut effectivement une complicité
de la france dans le génocide
merci beaucoup à vous alain gautier je
rappelle que vous êtes co fondateur du
collectif des parties civiles pour le
rwanda